our next guest dessert Empire is getting
a little sweeter award-winning Chef
Christina tozzi is the owner and founder
of the famous Milk Bar the National
Bakery chain is known for treats like
the compost cookie and their layered
birthday cakes her new book is all about
cookies a Milk Bar baking book shares
more than 100 new cookie recipes
Christina Tosi joins us now how are you
doing Christina good morning
hi Meg good morning how are you
it's good to have you on my my mouth is
salivating because we have all these
treats in front of us we'll get to that
in a second now you said your love for
baking all started with cookies how so
cookies were my entry into the kitchen I
was raised by these Fierce matriarchs
and we baked that's what we did in our
free time everything from like the
classic dense fudgy oatmeal cookie to a
bar cookie cookies were also like our
way out to create community and support
people and show love and make people
feel something feel seen to speak to
their soul cookies is where it all
became and cookies is like what Milk Bar
is all about and of course what this
cookbook's all about which is like a
homecoming for me
I know you say cookies are your safe
space you they're your secret to living
life on your own own terms and a cookie
is not just a cookie so what do you mean
when you say a cookie is not just a
cookie it seems like you have life
lessons even when it comes to cookies
big dessert out
it's a way for us to speak to people's
Souls it's a way to to make people sort
of
um feel something to indulge Etc but for
me the cookie is the underdog of the
pastry World it has this humility it's
portable it's transportable it's
shareable it's this low barrier to entry
there is a cookie that exists in nearly
every culture in this world and yet a
cookie in my opinion has infinite
possibility to break the rules and breed
creativity and really speak to someone's
taste buds so for me the cookie the
cookie needs more love and that's what
this I love I love the cookie Christina
the Chris the cookie is my is my number
one dessert and it's not optional by the
way my breakfast too Tony I'll see you
in the morning not even kidding I'm not
lying I feel like a Reebok's pump right
now I'm getting a little bigger every
day but I love those cookies and my mom
used to say uh life is unpredictable eat
dessert first and I live by those words
uh so tell us about the cookies on on
the table in front of us that you
dropped off these are great
okay so first off I brought you a slew
of like the classic Milk Bar cookies
dense and fudgy you can get them at our
bakeries Nationwide you can get them
online at lookbarscore.com those are
like the Hallmark of Milk bar but then I
also wanted to bring you some of my
favorite this babe right here is the
jelly donut Sammy
um it's a dough that's made using fryer
oil you put your favorite Jam or jelly
inside and then you can decorate it like
the top favorite donut
there are these what I call cookies that
like to party those giant cookies that's
what we call an XXL cookie or cookie
cake you can swing by our New York City
Flagship and create your own cookie but
it's a cookie that you can slice like a
slice of cake that you can share there's
a peanut butter chocolate caramel one
which is a love letter to my favorite
candy bar the take five candy bar
there's a chocolate one with pretzels
and potato chips I mean cookies really
are about being seen
um bringing your taste buds to life and
just giving you the possibility to like
shake you from sleepwalking Sea Life in
Color and so I figured I'd send you a
whole array yeah we thank you your
cookbook is beautifully done I could
lick the page you've got a de leche
cookie a peachy Shortcake cookie do you
have a favorite cookie if you had to
choose and then we'll let you go and I
mean that's like asking someone to
choose their favorite like grandkid and
your terms but I think it has to be the
fluffer Nutter it is this Sandy cookie
made with peanut butter you swirl some
marshmallow in it's actually all right
Christina this baby right here we gotta
get out of here we love you thank you
for the cookies all about cookies on
sale now wherever you buy your books
we'll see you tomorrow